the Coen brothers are a unique writing
and directing duo with a pretty broad
range to their style the films they've
made throughout their career have swung
between outright goofy and more serious
mood pieces Blood Simple their debut
film gives us a glimpse at their
filmmaking roots the things they value
in filmmaking that would blossom into
what makes the Coen Brothers writing and
direction so special unlike some of the
other directors we've looked at in this
series so far we can almost learn as
much from how Blood Simple differs from
the rest of their films as we can from
how it is similar to them let's look at
these differences and similarities and
examine how Joel and Ethan Coen made
Blood Simple and how that's affected
their approach to filmmaking throughout
their career the directors before series
is made possible by MU B go to MU be
calm slash Thomas flight for your 30-day
free trial
the Coen brothers personally raised the
money to make their first film from
private investors they made a short
promotional trailer and lugged a
projector into people's living rooms
gave their sales pitch and demo and
raised over half a million dollars one
small investment at a time violent
exploitation films were popular at the
time and relatively cheap to make so the
Cohens set out to make a film that would
play to that market Sam Raimi who the
Cohens have worked with several times
had received a lot of success in the
exploitation genre and the influence of
his films like Evil Dead is visible in
Blood Simple many auteur director's
avoid popular genre filmmaking but at
the very beginning the Cohens played to
a specific genre out of practicality to
help sell the film this trend has
continued though throughout their career
and they've made films that cover an
amazing range of genres film noir OC a
huckster or opportunity the real McCoy
musicals
[Music]
romantic comedies gangster films and
westerns while these films are
identifiable within their genre the
brothers always bring their unique flair
to the film often breaking or subverting
the genres conventions we can see this
clearly in Blood Simple which looks and
feels like an exploitation flick but
leans away from the violence and sleaze
that defines the genre and towards a
more cerebral story centered around
unique characters and a layered plot I
[Music]
can I'll crawl around without it their
ability to do this to take the coloring
page of a given genre and color outside
its lines in an artful way has produced
some of the most unique genre films of
the last few decades while the brothers
don't define an explicit style for
themselves and Blood Simple we do see
echoes of their first film and several
of their later films
we see an early version of the quiet
dramatic pacing of No Country for Old
Men both films contain scenes where
tension and suspense are built without
dialogue we see the sort of dark comedic
irony that will be prominent in many of
their later films especially Fargo and
the man who wasn't there the tension of
this scene and Blood Simple comes from
the dramatic irony of one of the
characters knowing more about a murder
than the other I don't know what you're
talking about and they use it a very
similar scenario to create dramatic
irony in the man who wasn't there the
Cohens often tell stories of characters
whose Harebrained Schemes have gone awry
leading to misunderstanding and
confusion which they use for comedic
effect the burglars have an incredible
knack for making films with a serious
deadpan tone as well as movies that are
downright goofy and absurd some of their
most interesting work manages to flirt
with both extremes have a good time
I don't like this kind of talk what to
copy and form and blood simple we see
their more serious side Raising Arizona
their second film shows us the other
side of the coin you go right back up
there and get me a toddler I need a baby
hi they got morning handle in a way the
movies are similar both stories of
illegal schemes gone awry but where one
is dark and suspenseful the other is
comedic and goofy the rest of the
brothers filmography will be spent
moving between these extremes sometimes
like with The Ballad of Buster Scruggs
both are exemplified within the same
work if there's a strong thread
throughout their filmography Eliza's
less in a specific visual style or type
of story and more in abstract
attractions - quirk and dark humor which
we see in blood simple a strong sense of
location is often important in their
films both simple's Texas locale is
emphasized at the beginning what I know
about Texas down here
and many of their films will similarly
brown themselves in a place often as
uniquely Illustrated as the characters
the Cohens right
the brothers frequently frame their
stories at the beginning using voiceover
the fact is nothing comes with a guy to
you grandfather was a lawman father to
me and him was sheriffs at the same time
him up and playing on me out here they
call Los Angeles the City of Angels I
didn't find it to be that exactly yeah I
worked in a barber shop but I never
considered myself a barber the endings
of their films often leave the audience
unsettled they rarely just hand you what
you were expecting or hoping for and
their writing tends to be intricate with
a great deal of attention paid to
repeating ideas and character humor how
did you cover the money it's been taken
care of the less you know about it the
better against you know this aggression
will not stand man just like the Cohens
having confined themselves to a single
type of story
they haven't confined themselves to a
specific visual style either the look of
a Coen Brothers film is largely dictated
by the cinematographer they are working
with for each film there's a great deal
of visual diversity in their filmography
from the start their collaboration with
DP Barry Sonnenfeld was marked by
vibrant and colorful lighting palettes
often featuring hard directional
lighting this stands in stark contrast
to the diffused naturalistic quality of
their films done with Roger Deakins and
the softer almost painterly look of
their films with Bruno del Nell their
look has evolved over time and in many
ways has become more subdued it's hard
to imagine shots like this one in their
more recent films and they don't use
wide lenses as often sand
they started working with Roger Deakins
the brothers have had repeated
collaborations with many great talents
but most of them are not featured and
Blood Simple palaver one in particular
stands out the brothers met and cast
Frances McDormand as their female lead
for Blood Simple it would be her
breakout role leading to a vibrant
successful career McDormand and joel
coen would get married the same year
Blood Simple was filmed and she would
become their most frequent collaborating
actor came along splatter brains all
over the interstate where would you be
there well the first films of some
directors set the tone for the rest of
their career what simple merely gives us
a hint and a taste of what was to come
while the Cohens admit it's a little
rough around some of its edges Blood
Simple showed the brothers have a unique
voice and it would be the first foray
into filmmaking of perhaps one of the
greatest writing and directing duo's
we've seen this is part four of the
directors before series the series is
brought to you by mu B mu B is a cinema
streaming and download service with a
focus on curation it's not just a site
that you go to to watch movies it's a
site you go to to find cool and
interesting things to watch that you're
not gonna find anywhere else they have
30 movies at a time every single day
they add a new one and take one away
it's a hand created library and if you
like the kind of directors and films I'm
talking about in this series you're
probably going to be interested in the
types of stuff that they curate you can
try it out for free for 30 days when you
go to MU b.com slash Thomas Flight
that's mu bi comm slash Thomas flight
for your 30 day free trial thanks again
to MU B for sponsoring the directors
before series thanks so much for
watching special thank you to my patreon
supporters go to patreon.com/scishow and
an ongoing basis I also want to thank
Julien Palmer of the discarded image for
his notes and feedback on this video
they were very helpful he recently made
a video about the Ballad of Buster
Scruggs which is really great talk to
you next time